it's an epidemic that's coming to us
it's this wave a pulse of of the virus
as it's spreading from person to person
and growing exponentially and the reason
that this is very important is that
let's say for the sake of argument a
hundred thousand Americans are going to
die of this condition in the next year
it makes all the difference in the world
whether those hundred thousand died over
the course of the next year or whether
all hundred thousand died in the next
month if they die in the next month
they're gonna overwhelm our health care
system and many more Americans will die
than would have died if we allowed our
health care system and our supply chain
to work joining me today is a
sociologist and physician known for his
research on social networks and on the
socio-economic bio social and
evolutionary determinants of behavior
health and longevity Nick Christakis
welcome back to the Rubin report thank
you for having me Dave I'm glad to have
you back wish we could be doing this
live but obviously we're practicing a
little social distancing right now with
everything going on with Corona I've
been trying to find a wide array of
people to talk to you put out what I
thought was a really fantastic Twitter
thread I rarely send people to Twitter
but you put out a great Twitter thread
that covered this through all of the
disciplines that I just read there in
your bio which are quite extensive so
let's just start one at a time the the
two things that people have heard the
most about at the moment social
distancing and flattening the curve can
you just explain both and why they're
important right now yeah so the virus
takes advantage of the fact that we are
social animals that we assemble in
groups that we have friends that we
touch each other and hug each other and
now and it uses those connections that
we assemble ourselves into these
networks it uses those connections as a
highway to travel through our species
and so the challenge for us right now is
how to interrupt that highway how to
break the paths that the virus uses to
travel from person to person to person
to person
the reason that's important is that this
flattening the curve idea so so we're
gonna engage in social distancing we're
gonna stop interacting with each other
we're gonna keep physically apart from
each other that's the most important
thing in fact I've been advocating for a
shift in terminology to physical
distancing from social distancing in
other words we we can still interact
socially but from a distance when you
and I are doing now okay and uh and so
we want physical distance e we want to
iron ease we want to like you know bond
together at the same time as we are sort
of separating from each other in terms
physically anyway the reason we're
engaging in that physical distancing is
to cut the path through the network and
the reason we're doing that is to
flatten the curve what does that mean
well it's an epidemic that's coming to
us it's this wave a pulse of of the
virus as it's spreading from person to
person and growing exponentially and the
reason that this is very important is
that let's say for the sake of argument
a hundred thousand Americans are going
to die of this condition in the next
year it makes all the difference in the
world whether those hundred thousand
died over the course of the next year or
whether all hundred thousand died in the
next month if they die in the next month
they're gonna overwhelm our healthcare
system and many more Americans will die
than would have died if we allowed our
health care system and our supply chain
to work so we want to flatten the curve
we've got this peak of a curve where
everyone you know the epidemic is coming
at us and it's gonna hit lots of people
at the same time we want to stop it from
doing that and flatten the curve and
push it out into the future and when we
do that we achieve a number of
objectives first of all at any given
point fewer people are sick so our
health care system can take care of them
many more might live as a result of that
second we we push some of the cases out
into the future so that maybe some of
the people that get sick eventually will
get sick at a time when we've invented a
vaccine or we know better how to treat
the people so we also gain that benefit
by flattening the curve and as I said
not only do we decompress our healthcare
system not only do we push people into
the future when we might be better able
to
for them but we reduce mortality as well
so maybe instead of a hundred thousand
dying maybe ninety thousand died if we
push it forward so that's why we're
social distancing and that's what
flattening the curve means so I guess
the obvious follow-up then is do we have
any evidence that the things that we are
doing at the moment or being told to do
is working is working is the is the
curve being flattened we we cannot know
yet because we have not had adequate
testing in this country we don't have
adequate surveillance like they did in
China and Korea and so we really can't
be sure we know that
type this type of behavior this social
distancing behavior the banning of
public gatherings the closure of schools
the reduction in group size the self
isolation we know that that works from
other epidemics but we cannot yet know
how much it's working in the United
States right now because we don't have
the kind of surveillance we need to see
it so I think when people hear about
social distancing and as you called it
physical distancing I think people are
confused or worried what about the
people that are actually in the house
with them family kids parents whatever
it is that might have to go out and then
come back into the house yeah yeah
that's a risk that you that we run and
that the Chinese ran when they you know
lock down nine hundred and thirty
million people in their countries since
January the 25th so typically what you
do is is you you try to compress all of
your shopping in fact Americans should
begin to be doing that right now instead
of going out three times a week to buy
stuff go out once a week compress
everything minimize the amount of time
you're out and about when the person
does go out they should ideally try to
wash their hands frequently not press
elevator buttons the Chinese have all
these ingenious things where when you go
into an elevator there's like a little
pin cushion of toothpicks and you take a
toothpick you press your button and then
you discard the toothpick so that you're
not touching buttons because the the
virus can spread on smooth surfaces
that's called fomites so so a person
leaving the household should do that if
someone in the household does get sick
and they are tested positive you can in
principle isolate that person for two
weeks from other members of the
household or
the worst-case scenario they infect the
other people in the household but
nevertheless it's them constrained to
one household keep in mind that most
people infected by this pathogen do fine
you know it uh it the great majority of
people will have no symptoms or will
have minor symptoms some people however
may be twenty five percent overall will
get serious will get sick and of those
maybe a fifth of those so total of five
percent maybe of the people infected
will get seriously ill and then of
course on average we don't know exactly
how many of the people who are infected
will die and the reason again we don't
know is we don't have good testing so we
we don't know what the what the
denominator is we don't know you know of
10,000 people who are infected we know
that because they were tested let's say
what happens to them and how many of
them get sick and how many of them meet
ICU care and how many of them died we we
don't know that denominator accurately
but our best estimate is that of those
infected some are between half a percent
and one and a half percent will die and
and it is that's a large number but it's
very graded by age so if you're younger
than 25 your risk of death is very small
maybe 0.2% that's a big risk for a young
person but nevertheless it's a small
risk and then middle aged people around
50 or 60 it's about 1% and then above 80
it's about 20% so it's a very steep
curve with age do you have a
recommendation than if you're in the
household right now and you're any of
these ages let's say you're 25 you're 50
and and you're 80 let's just go with
those three ages and you're not feeling
great
should you be then trying to go to the
hospital or I guess maybe if you're 80
you are or or just stay home and deal
with it the best again yeah in general
so in general one of the things we all
need to be very good about doing right
now is giving our healthcare workers a
break so you should not be going to the
hospital with the sniffles right now
there are a few things that Americans
should do you should get a flu shot one
of the reasons you should get a flu shot
is not because the flu shot has it
prevents you from getting coronavirus it
does not but if you get a flu shot it
lowers your risk of actually getting the
flu and therefore you won't go to the
hospital
with the flu and now is not a good time
for you to be burden in our health care
system for your own sake or for the sake
of the system furthermore going to the
hospital if you're not actually sick if
there a lot of actually or if you're
just mildly sick there are a lot of
actually seriously sick people there you
might get the germ from them so it's not
like in a hospital waiting room is not a
time to be right now if you unless you
actually need it so generally speaking
the symptoms of coronavirus are variable
you should have a fever above 101.5 it's
in about 85% of people not everyone but
most people have a fever a dry cough
would be a symptom and then there's a
shortness of breath certainly if you
have shortness of breath and a fever
absolutely you should go to the hospital
and then there's a whole host of other
symptoms at lower percentages so if
you're a 25 year old person and you know
you have a runny nose and low-grade
temperature and some muscle aches it's
probably not growing a virus stay home
until you get sicker that would be a
reasonable choice you know if you're an
older person then you should have a
lower threshold and ideally if you went
we would test you right and but again we
don't have enough testing yet we're
hopefully the country will get better at
that in the coming months yeah all right
I want to keep going through this
Twitter thread because you hit okay
every you hit it just sort of it at
every possible level so you talked about
reasons to close schools even if kids
there aren't sick yeah I mean school
closures there's a lot of debate about
this there are two kinds of school
closures and most of the country's
shutting the schools anyway now so this
point is is behind us I was sending out
this information like three or four
weeks ago but school closures are two
kinds there's reactive school closure
when there's a case in the school and
you close the school and that's pretty
uncontroversial I mean most parents
teachers public health experts there's
an outbreak of an epidemic in the school
let's close the school the and it's been
shown that if you do that you lower the
if you close the schools in an in an
area you lower the cumulative prevalence
of the condition by about 25 percent and
postpone the epidemic by a week or two
which is good so reactive school closure
is helpful but you know it's not as good
as we can do that even better is
something called proactive school
closure when you close
schools even before there's a case in
the schools for instance you living in a
mid-sized town there's a case in the
community it's something called a
community-acquired case so it's not like
someone from Italy or China flew to your
town landed had symptoms and you
diagnosed them that would be an imported
case maybe you could isolate that person
and and and self-quarantine the people
who they connected with no we're talking
about a situation in which someone in
the community is diagnosed and we have
no idea where they got it they're like a
canary in the coal mine and if that's
happening you can be quite confident
that within a week or two it's gonna be
in the school so why not close the
school now reduce the force of the
epidemic by decreasing social mixing and
ironically even though the kids aren't
affected by this condition they still
can transmit the pathogen even though
they themselves aren't sick and
furthermore one of the ways that school
closure works is precisely because it
compels the parents to stay home so it
reduces the parents interacting with
each other that's how it works in part
yeah and it sounds like we've we've
basically done this pretty well maybe a
little later than you wanted to but it
sounds like now we're there right now
definitely definitely later than we
wanted to and for schools that are still
open what I would strongly recommend and
my wife and I had an article in the
Atlantic about this a few days ago is if
you insist on staying open and I don't
think that's the best course of action
at least you can implement a whole host
of other harm mitigation strategies for
example give parents the choice if they
want to keep their kids home they should
stay home I want to mention this because
it's also relevant to employers and and
workers allowing any worker who can work
at home to work at home it's not just
good for that worker from like their
selfish point of view it helps everybody
because you reduce the number of people
at the office so only the people that
have to be there should be there
same with schools if some parents want
to keep the school should let them keep
their kids home you can broaden drop-off
and pickup hours so not everyone is
arriving between 8 & 8 15 to drop off
their kids bumping against each other as
they come through the door parents
interacting let's say you give a
45-minute drive
it needs a bit more manpower on the part
of the school but you reduce the social
density and pick up and drop off cancel
staff meetings provide cafeteria seating
broaden the lunch hour and have the kids
sit every other chair these are things
that schools can do if they insist on
staying open maybe in our southern
states for instance where maybe the
virus hasn't hit so much yet but that
nevertheless are helpful so you sort of
hit this one already but do you want to
add anything generally on how the flu
spreads within social networks well
first of all we call this the flu and
there's a broad category of respiratory
diseases influenza the flu is a
particular kind of virus this is a
corona virus which is a little different
but I call it the flu to maybe you know
I'm lazy you know but this is a kind of
flu the corona virus there are other
corona bite like the common cold is
caused by about 200 different viruses
about five of them are corona viruses
just like covin 19 or Tsarskoe v2 which
is affecting us now and we've gotten
used to it just to just to cut ahead to
the chase the ultimate outcome of this
situation is that a new virus has been
introduced into our species it's gonna
become what's called endemic it's just
gonna be there all the time like the
common cold like the flu we hope it'll
reduce in its severity we hope we humans
will eventually slowly become immune to
it and we will get sort of herd immunity
so some people will continue to get this
forever now but hopefully at less
intensity and not all at once so that
our health care system can care for them
anyway so the corona virus and the flu
and influenza and other pathogens Rhino
virus that causes the common cold these
are all cause respiratory disorders and
the corona virus is one of them I
actually forgot your question I'm sorry
the question was was how it spreads
within social networks which you've sort
of been hitting throughout this yeah
yeah so it spreads and it spreads
exactly across social ties and in the
Twitter thread you're alluding to I have
an animation that shows if you map a
network you can see it like light up and
one of the things that's been so
difficult for people to understand and
it's a little bit related to this
network idea is that epidemics starts
slowly you know for the longest time it
seems like nothing is happening but what
but the it's in the nature of
exponential growth that nothing is
happening nothing is happening nothing
is happening and then all of a sudden a
lot happens and this has been why it's
been so difficult for many Americans to
appreciate they look around and they're
like nothing's happening but if we
monitor the situation we see the cases
are doubling the virus is on the loose
we go from 10 a week later to 20 a week
later to 40 and we think oh they're just
40 cases in the United States who cares
then it's 80 then it's 160 cases but
then before you know we have 10,000
20,000 40,000 100,000 200,000 and it's
just on the loose and and that's why we
everyone is so alarmed right now all the
public health professionals so that's
actually the perfect segue to what your
next tweet and the thread was which is
how these epidemics come in waves and
then interestingly how this is actually
related to weather yes so one of the
things to understand about this is that
is is that probably judging from
previous pandemics maybe 40 percent of
Americans will be infected with this
maybe less maybe 10 or 20% maybe up to
60% with in 1957 pandemic ultimately
about 40 percent of Americans were
infected and and and but but it comes in
waves so we're hit by the first pulse of
it typically in the summer for a
combination of reasons including that
human beings go outside we're not as
densely packed maybe the the ventilation
outside reduces the transmission of the
the pathogen maybe the heat or the
humidity play a role in reducing the
transmissibility of the pathogen so our
behavior changes the biology of the
pathogen is such that the temperature
and humidity affected transmission tends
to decline but then the virus has gone
to the southern hemisphere where it's
winter there during our summer and then
when we return to work in school in
September it comes back this is a very
typical scenario so unfortunately it's
likely not certain and I need to again
emphasize that everything I'm telling
you today is based on the best available
knowledge to the best of my knowledge it
possible that a year from now people
will watch this video and and think I
was right about this and wrong about
that and that's just the knowledge we
have now this pathogens only been with
us for three months I mean it just it
started we think in mid-december in in
Wuhan and it started spreading around
the world in mid-january it was already
in Seattle by mid January we know from
genetic analyses and then was sort of
spreading and now here we are March 18th
you know two months after mid-january
that's not a lot of time for scientists
to figure out what's going on
so anyway so we think it'll spend the
summer mostly in the in the southern
hemisphere although we'll have some
cases and then it'll come back in the
fall in the 1918 pandemic the second
wave was deadlier than the first wave so
in 1957 that wasn't as much the case so
we don't know exactly what's gonna
happen but then they'll probably be a
second maybe a third wave and eventually
basically we'll get used to it and it'll
just sort of be there all the time so
since you mentioned Seattle and we're
talking about whether so Seattle it
sounds like they've got a strange
situation or a more severe situation
going on there perhaps it's also it also
rains a lot there I'm here in SoCal
where it's sunny
you know sunny in 70 everyday it
although it has been raining the last
week I mean could that alone just the
the weather patterns like that affect
any of this well the Chinese scientists
have done some research on this we don't
know is the answer to that question
people hope their hints at multiple
directions I do not think we're gonna
have a complete weather cure that is to
say I don't think the disease is simply
gonna disappear because of the weather
the evidence is conflicting if I had to
guess I would say that probably will get
some reduction in cases from the warmth
and the humidity but it's hard to know
what that the Chinese did some analyses
because their country's so large where
they looked at transmission all
throughout China and in some parts of
China it was hot and some parts cold and
some parts humid and some parts not and
they kind of looked and saw where it was
transmission the worst and it seems like
optimal transmission is at around 40
degrees Fahrenheit on average daily
temperature
so cold but so when you get much cold or
much hotter that seems to be better less
transmission but not zero and then they
looked at humidity and it looks like
very dry weather is bad
so humidity is less than five percent
that's not particularly good but if you
look at weather patterns for where the
virus is struck so far it seems that
countries closer to the equator seem to
be doing better so it's a mixed picture
I don't know the answer but if I had to
guess I do not think I think the weather
will make some difference but I don't
think it'll be a you know a definitive
difference so I think I'm actually gonna
skip the next one in the thread because
you were talking about vulnerable groups
but since you're talking about because I
think we've sort of hit that already
unless there's anything else you want to
add about older people or sick people I
think yeah I mean I think we have to be
mindful of people on dialysis people
with chronic illnesses institutionalized
people the elderly homeless populations
and one of the things that's really
important to understand about a pandemic
is that it's the great equalizer we're
all in this together actually the reason
you should care about let's say the
homeless or people who are chronically
ill is not just because you should be
kind and compassionate and altruistic
it's actually your own selfish interest
too because we do not want populations
that are reservoirs of this pathogen we
want to take care of everybody so we all
can be safer this is why social
distancing even if when you practice
social distancing you're actually
showing kindness to others one of the
ironies is that people think oh I'm
gonna be brave and show kindness by
shaking people's hands and being out and
about ironically that's not the kind
thing to do the kind thing to do is to
remove yourself from circulation so that
you're not circulating the pathogen
that's the best thing you can do for
your your group or your society yeah I
actually didn't mean to diminish any of
those groups but because you were
hitting on the China part which was the
next tweet I was gonna jump over that so
you actually in the thread you called it
you were no I know I know I wasn't
suggesting I was just saying I was
taking advantage of the opening to point
out to people in case it wasn't obvious
why it's not just a question of
compassion it's it's actually in our
self-interest to take care of these
populations so you
a little bit about China you know we
live in this time where it's like half
the people are saying China unleash this
on the world half the people are saying
China has done nothing wrong
you called in your Twitter thread you
called China's response astonishing can
you explain that well first of all we we
know we would know from genetic analyses
if this was an engineered weapon and
that's a conspiracy theory there's
absolutely no evidence that any such
thing happened okay and so they
certainly didn't release it deliberately
and and because they're killing their
own people and because of the study so
that's ridiculous no what I was
describing is China because of its
totalitarian or authoritarian rather
government and it's collectivist culture
was able to put nine hundred and thirty
million people under a kind of
home-based quarantine beginning January
the 25th for like eight weeks it never
in the history of public health has such
so many people been under such
restriction for so long to my knowledge
it's unbelievable what they were able to
do because of their culture and and
their government and I call this a
social nuclear weapon because it gives
you a sense of what they were fighting
you know the power of this pathogen that
they were confronting that they resorted
to this China did not decide to do this
for fun and what I was trying to
communicate with that thread that was
now weeks ago was to try to get
attention in the United States like look
what's happening in China this this is
not gonna just stay there this is not
like a Chinese problem that's you know
they've decided to put a billion people
under home arrest you know for two
months for fun we need to prepare we
need to think about this because the
virus is gonna reach our shores in fact
already when I was writing that it had
reached our shores this is what happens
in pandemics no matter where the disease
starts it spreads around the globe and
by the time you're aware of it even if
you're aware of it 30 days after
inception
it's too late given movements of people
even frankly a hundred years ago given
movements of people on on steamboats and
on trains and and big compact cities the
virus spreads
uh so anyway so I was you know I was
trying to describe what the Chinese had
done and and it is astonishing what they
did and they have brought down their
cases in a country of 1.4 billion people
to you know under under now it's like I
don't even know it's like ten cases a
day or something in the whole nation
yeah so this is unfortunately what we
are facing in our country and we have
different strengths and different
weaknesses compared to China one of
their weaknesses we have an open a
commitment to free and open expression
in our society and in China
unfortunately the doctor who first tried
to sound the alarm doctor when Langley
he was brought in on charges of rumor
mongering you know he was he was
basically using the Facebook equivalent
in China and messaging his friends and
saying oh my god I'm seeing all these
patients in the hospital with his
particular kind of pneumonia I'm worried
we have a new pathogen and the local
authorities called him in and you know
accused him of rumor mongering which is
not something he's not a crime in her
society so again no so I mean so our
strengths in our society include our
wealth art our openness our our
tremendous scientists but we haven't
been playing to those strengths we've
not been listening to our scientists
we've not been deploying our wealth we
we haven't been acting the way we should
be acting and taking our strengths to
cope with this and that you know the
Chinese use different strengths and they
frankly cope very effectively with this
I should say just to be clear what the
Chinese had accomplished was they
stopped the spread of the pathogen but
they did not eradicate it so the
pathogen is still there and it will come
back even to China as it will come back
to us but they have bought themselves a
huge amount of time to organize their
response now so they don't lose you know
countless lives okay so actually I think
most of the other things in the thread
you you've already hit so I'll only ask
you one more and then I just want to do
two or three audience questions real
quick
you mentioned the nineteen you mentioned
the 1957 flu pandemic before can you
talk about some of the similarities and
differences to what we're dealing
yeah well 57
19:18 of course was the big one that was
the so-called Spanish flu which swept
the world you know killed many millions
of people including our country it was a
different time
of course people were starving because
of the war there was a lot of disruption
because of the war and it was a
different pathogen and you know many and
there was no modern medicine no
antibiotics even against bacteria and
many people in that we think many of
those people died not just because of
the viral infection but then their lungs
got so-called super infected with
bacterial pneumonia which killed them
many people so a lot was different then
and we earlier we talked about how the
it came in three waves and you know it
was awful and there was a great
depression of course afterwards as well
so I don't think
around the same time anyway I don't
think um I don't think that this
pandemic is thankfully gonna be that bad
but the nearest analog I can see even
though it was a different pathogen and
in some ways at different epidemiology
for example in 1957 the pathogen also
killed young people whereas this one
does not
I think 57 might be a good model for
what we're facing so every 10 years or
so and reliably but at an unpredictable
time the world has a pandemic most of
your listeners will remember SARS or
h1n1 or MERS and those have petered out
so people weren't taking them they'll
take them seriously and they Peter out
for a variety of reasons ironically one
of the reasons is that sometimes they're
too deadly for instance SARS was about
ten times as deadly as though as the
kovat that we're facing now and when a
disease is too deadly it kills its
victim too fast so the person can't
spread it so this particular pathogen
we're facing has sort of middling level
lethality it's neither too benign not
nor too deadly it's not as deadly as the
1918 virus and it has middling level
transmissibility it's not very difficult
to transmit and it's not too hard to
transmit and it's sort of in the middle
there and in my view it seems to be
behaving similar to the 57 pandemic
which should be clear some of your
listeners older ones may remember it but
many people won't but and and part of
the reason people don't remember it is
we didn't have the same media
environment then and of course people
were dealing with polio and other deadly
diseases but that pandemic swept over
the United States and killed we think
about 110,000 people which back then was
half as deadly as all of the cancer in
the United States so today if we have a
57 pandemic we're talking hundreds of
thousands of Americans dying from kovat
if the disease is half as deadly as
cancer so as a group so it's serious it
could be quite serious I'd also want to
just take an opportunity again to say we
don't know exactly what's gonna happen
and what's very important for your
listeners is to understand that
despite political polarization
and despite our desire to simplify our
choices should we have rice crispies or
should we have cornflakes there are
shades of gray and there's nuance when
it comes to serious policy dilemmas and
and serious scientific questions so
there's a range of outcomes we could
observe in the United States from this
we don't know exactly what's going to
happen but at best 35,000 Americans are
going to die in my view at best and it's
quite possible that 20% of Americans
will get infected that's 60 million
Americans in the next year and our best
estimate is that half a percent of those
people might die
that's 300,000 Americans dying in the
next year of this condition and that's
possible
it we're not sure it's gonna happen it
might not happen I hope it doesn't
happen but it's possible and that is a
very very heavy burden that is about
that's 1957 pandemic you know that's
half as deadly as cancer approximately
so so that's why everyone is taking it
seriously so I got a ton of questions
specifically for you because I posted in
in the Rubin report community I posted
that we're having you on I had everyone
look at the thread so what I thought I'd
do is I'll just ask you two or three now
and then I'm just gonna email you a one
email with all these questions and maybe
as you have a little time here and there
you can throw some things on Twitter for
that or that or it may be a little more
specific obviously that's totally up to
you but I'll just ask you two or three
now I thought this was really
interesting and I got I got a lot of
this type of question what is the
acceptable level of risk in terms of
disease and death that were willing to
accept in order to have a normally
functioning society and healthy economy
well I would ask you to think about what
we do when it comes to mining safety or
other dangerous occupations like whether
we quip our police with bulletproof
vests for example we spend money in a
preventive way to prevent deaths in
hazardous occupations all the time
now we don't spend limitlessly you know
we don't we don't equip each police
officer we expect people to take some
risk of death we don't spend limits
limitlessly even to secure our highways
you know not every highway is a divided
highway which we know is safer because
it would cost too much so there's some
calculation we make about how much money
we're willing to spend in order to save
lives and what you have to understand in
this case is that we're dealing with a
threat and incidentally death is
expensive - like all these people dying
and consuming healthcare is expensive so
preventing those deaths saves us money
as well I acknowledge as most experts do
that you know taking our economy is a
devastating thing but I I would suggest
that if people started dying like flies
if 300,000 Americans started dying our
economy would have tanked anyway so so
so the the problem again is is not that
300,000 extra Americans are gonna die
although that's not good it's that
they're gonna die very compressed we're
not just spreading them out and so
that's a devastating blow to our society
no matter what so so I guess I would say
that in answer to your question that we
always are willing to pay some economic
costs to save lives and I acknowledge
that going into a into a major
depression or a major recession and
possibly a depression is a huge cost for
our society but I would suggest to you
that we would likely have faced that
anyway if we had done nothing but then
we also would have had all of these
deaths alright so I think it's necessary
yeah all right so we're just gonna do
two more and then I know you I know
you've got a crazy day ahead of you and
then I'm just gonna email you some of
these and maybe you can get to some of
them but there were also a bunch about
this is there any confirmation whether
airborne transmission is possible I mean
if someone has it and you're at the
store and you're avoiding everybody the
best
you can and you're wearing gloves and
the rest of it but somebody breathes on
you or sneezes on you or something like
that I think there's a little confusion
as to what airborne transmission
actually means that may be yes
so droplet transmission is is when a
when a liquid like I sneeze or cough or
spit and they're droplets that go
through the air and land on you and your
nose or your mouth and transmits it to
you and that's why we're supposed to say
four or five or six feet away from each
other because if I sneeze and I'm six
feet away from you the droplets would go
through the air and then fall onto the
ground and not reach you airborne is
when tiny particulates maybe the virus
itself are floating through the air
maybe and can reach you we believe that
there is both droplet and airborne
transmission and there probably is
probably fecal transmission as well
which is a little bit concerning of this
pathogen and something called fo my
transmission which is that the pathogen
can can stay on surfaces especially
smooth surfaces so porous things like
paper money or fabrics less so but
smooth surfaces like elevator buttons
doorknobs
kitchen counters a more can stay more so
but the virus is also very fragile its
encapsulated in a lipid coat when when
the virus viruses work by taking over
our own cells and they grow inside
ourselves and then they explode out of
our cells and as they explode out they
take a little bit of our cell membrane
with them so they're encapsulated in
this lipid membrane but and they and
that helps them to beat more
transmissible but it makes them very
vulnerable to soap so cleanliness this
is why washing your hands and when you
wash your hands you should wash between
your fingers and the backs of your hands
many people are saying sing the Happy
Birthday song twice while you wash your
hands it's true but that does kill the
virus so when you go out and about if
you avoid touching your face if you wash
your hands before you return home that
is a very basic hygiene that's actually
very helpful and experiments have shown
this by the way it's not just old wives
tales like people actually do studies
where they touch stuff and then they
wash their hands and they see if the
buyers goes away yeah all right so the
last one then is I got a couple of
versions of this that you know we're all
concerned about this
and even the way I'm trying to do these
shows I'm not trying to overload people
too much and I don't want everyone glued
to their TVs endlessly what what else do
you make of just sort of the human
condition in the midst of a pandemic
like this well as you know because we
talked about it the last time you and I
met I just wrote this book yeah you've
got a whole book about it it's right
over there
I know I wrote this book called
blueprint the evolutionary origins of a
good society and as you know Dave I'm an
optimist I believe in human beings I
marvel at our capacity for goodness I
recognize our capacity for evil and
selfishness and and tribalism and and
violence but I also revere and admire
our capacity for love and friendship and
cooperation and teaching in fact all of
these are things that we are using right
now to confront this virus we are
banding together and working together to
fight off this invader we are using our
capacity for teaching the reason we know
what to do in this case is because
previous humans who confronted this
virus wrote down here's what you do when
you're facing a pandemic you literally
can go there's a book right here I can
look over and see it's called national
strategy for influenza pandemics like
there are books that you can open up
like a cookbook and they say here's what
you do when there's a pandemic it's
amazing we can transmit this knowledge
to each other and therefore cope with
this with this enemy the the virus that
is attacking us so this is why I'm
hopeful and optimistic the virus will
eventually pass our species will survive
it is unfortunate that many will die we
don't know how many the virus will
become endemic we will see the other
side of this but we do have to work
together as a society to shore up our
industries to protect our healthcare
workers from whom we're gonna ask
tremendous amounts and from whom we're
gonna ask to take tremendous risks it's
one thing when I was a doctor and I mean
I'm a physician and I don't see patients
anymore but when I was seeing patients
especially in the 1990s the HIV epidemic
was very prominent and there was a lot
of concern that if you took care of
patients with HIV and a lot of those
patients were gay or they were from
Haiti or they were drug users they were
groups that back then were especially
stigmatized and so there was a lot of
like kind of oh well you know we won't
take care of those people and and there
was fear among healthcare providers like
if you stuck them and you got their
blood on you you might contract this
deadly disease but we were expected to
take personal risks we were expected to
care for these patients it's a calling
to be a doctor or a nurse it's a it's a
it's a moral obligation and so we expect
a huge amount from our doctors and
nurses and health care providers right
now we expect them to take these risks
but it's not the same to expect them to
take the risks with the proper equipment
versus to send them to certain death
that is to say without masks gloves
protective equipment and so I'm very
concerned that we don't we're not taking
this seriously we we we don't have the
right equipment to equip our frontline
medical personnel to deal with this and
this is why I'm also upset that we
squandered the six weeks that the
Chinese bought for us by locking down
their nation we should have been
planning to equip our hospitals with
this personal protective equipment with
ventilators with staffing with
procedures at which we can discuss it's
too technical and boring to confront
this epidemic so we're running up we're
behind now is the problem and I hope
very much we can catch up and this is
again why social distancing is so
important to slow this thing down so we
can let our supply chain our scientists
are our politicians frankly you know
catch up so that we can cope with this
well Nick I I always consider you one of
the cleanest clearer clearest thinkers
that we've got and especially in a time
like this so I appreciate you taking the
time and maybe we'll get you back on in
a couple weeks as this thing continues
don't thank you for very much for having
me Dave and thank you to your listeners
have Ron we're obviously in some
unchartered territory with coronavirus
and our plan here is to help you make as
much sense of the situation and a non
alarmist fashion as possible if you're
looking for reliable information from
experts on the front lines of the
pandemic check out our coronavirus
playlist which will keep adding updates
- right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe